(upbeat hip hop music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing show.
The number one podcast for growing
and scaling your business
with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell
and we're from Think Media
and if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now online.
So whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
Well on today's episode,
we are bringing you
another keynote from our
annual video conference,
Grow With Video Live.
It's a conference we
host here in Las Vegas
every single year
and this year is going to be epic.
But we want to share with
you a front row seat,
VIP all-access recording
to the session that I did
at Grow With Video Live.
And I'm excited to share with you
how you can overcome the seven enemies
that are keeping you from
crushing it with video right now.
You know we really fight a lot of things
when it comes to having
confidence on camera,
being able to press that record button
and create content over the year
and so I want to dive into
these seven enemies right now.
This session for me is something
that I really wanted to bring to you
because I, like most creators,
fight these enemies daily.
And so for this session today
we are going to press record.
We're gonna go through and the
overcoming the seven enemies
keeping you from crushing it with video.
And here's the thing.
Pressing record changed my life.
Like Sean said, four years ago
I had never uploaded a video.
I mean, that's crazy to think
I'm standing on this stage
but four years ago I was
afraid to put my smartphone
in front of my face and
just say hi to the world.
And so as we go through these today
we're gonna crush and
tackle external enemies
as well as internal enemies
because I know as a creator just like you,
I've struggled with both of these.
The external and the internal.
So let's go ahead and just jump right in.
I like to just jump into sessions.
So we're gonna first tackle
the external enemies.
Now you saw this on
Seans's slides as well.
83% of marketers would increase
their reliance on video
as a strategy is there were no obstacles
like time, resources and budget.
Now as you saw, I have a
pretty full life, right?
I mean I think we all do.
Raise your hand if you feel like
you have a pretty full life.
Yes, okay so I am not
alone in this situation.
Now a few years ago
as I was starting my
entrepreneurial journey,
I was a mess.
I mean I'll just admit
it, I was a complete mess.
I was trying to juggle my
family and starting a business
and having failures and all of the things.
And a book was placed in my
hand called "Essentialism".
Has anyone read the book
"Essentialism" before?
All right well it is an amazing book
that I highly recommend that you read
and one of the things that
they tackle in that book
that was completely
revolutionary in my life
was the idea of the lack of time.
And the author of this book
says "If you don't prioritize
your life, someone else will."
You hear that?
If you do not step up
and prioritize your time,
your 24 hours, guess what?
Someone else's agenda is
going to ride into there.
And like Lauren said,
you know, I'm a wife.
I'm a mom of three.
I'm running this business
but there are some key staples
of learning through productivity
that I want to share with you today.
So here are my five, four, five,
I forget how many I put on here
but let's go through them.
Here's my productivity tips
that I use every single day in my life.
And I want to pass these on to you
because these have been what
has gotten me here today.
So number one is I am a preacher
of calender time blocking.
Do I have any time blockers
in the audience today?
(few people cheering)
Let me tell you, it is
life changing is it not?
It's amazing!
So here's how I do this.
If you are new to calendars,
I'm gonna show you
an example of what my
typical week would look like.
But for what this looks like right now
is I want you to focus
on what is called an IPA.
Can you say that with me?
IPA.
Okay, what is that?
An income producing activities.
Income producing activities.
Now we can fill our days
with a lot of things, right?
Like raise your hand
if you're like "I could
fill my day Heather
"without a calendar, easy."
No one?
Okay well you're all awesome.
Okay so income producing activities.
These are the things
that are actually gonna
move your business forward.
These are the things that are actually
gonna move your relationships forward.
These are the income producing activities
that are gonna get you to
the next step in your life.
And so what does this look like for me?
Well here's what a typical week
in Heather Torres's life would look like.
So what this, this is, guys
are saying "Oh my gosh."
(laughs)
I'm a busy woman, you know?
Here's what this looks like.
Now I am a color coater.
Any other color coaters?
Yes!
I just love all the colors
they have on Google Calendar.
It's amazing.
So this is a digital calendar that I use
and I love digital
because let's be honest,
life changes pretty fast, right?
So I worked on the regular type
of calendar for a long time
trying to color coat with my pens
and you know, playing my journaling music
and all that stuff
but it just stopped working
because life changes.
I have three kids, I'm running
a business, all of the things
so I need to be able
to change these things
at a moment's notice.
So if you're looking on the screen here
I want you to see that
what I do first in the day
is actually work on my side hustle.
Anyone in here with a side hustle?
Yes.
The first thing I do is
work on my side hustle.
Now for me my side hustle right now
actually is my YouTube
channel, The Homeschool House.
So on top of the other things we're doing,
that is a passion project of mine
and I want to set aside time
where I can move that forward.
Then I have my family time
but then when I clock into work,
the first thing that I
do is not check email.
The first thing I do
is not go to a meeting.
The first thing that I use
this creative brain for
is the IPA's.
That's the first thing that I do.
And so I use that time as sacred time
to write that email that
I know I need to get out
to my customers.
Or I use that time to
make the video content
that needs to be made.
That is sacred time that's
gonna move our business forward.
So then after that you'll
see that we have admin.
That's where you fill in emails.
That is other people's agenda
and so that comes later.
And then past that I have
additional work time,
family time and shows you there.
But that is what calendar
blocking in a nutshell looks like.
Who can commit to calendar
blocking this next week?
Anyone want to commit to that?
Awesome, love that.
Okay well you know what happens
when you are working on your IPA's?
You start creating some income
because you're working on
income producing activities.
And so what can happen there
is now you have the funds
to be able to outsource tasks
that you do not need to be doing.
That is a huge blocker
when I'm with clients
is they are wanting to do it all.
Anyone feel like that?
They feel like I have to do it all.
I can never release that thing.
I can never just give that away.
I don't want to hire a person for that.
Well guess what?
That is actually what's gonna
move your business forward.
So when you start doing those IPA's
you can start outsourcing
and you can start using
smart tools that are online.
So what we use here at Think Media
as well as, here's some of the
tools we use at Think Media
but we also, if you've not noticed,
we have hired a lot of
people on Think Media.
And you know what?
That is scary.
Like let's be honest.
Hiring a human who needs to
pay their bills is on you?
That is a hard thing.
But you know what?
That is actually going
to produce more income
in your business.
It's kind of a weird blocker.
But these are some of the tools
that we use here at Think Media
and you'll notice I don't
have like an entire slide
full of things, right?
There are four main things
that we're using here at Think Media.
Why?
'Cause I don't want to be
learning more software.
Anyone else not really
into all the software?
You're like I want to learn this
and I need to do this and
this plugs into that thing
and into this thing and into that thing
and you're like, what
am I doing with my time?
I am not a software developer, okay?
I am not a software developer.
But these are the things we use.
As a team we use Google Calendar.
Everyone on our team,
everyone including my husband
and soon to be my children
will be on Google Calendar.
Why?
Because we're syncing our lives together.
We're making sure that IPA's
are crossing each other
and we're working smarter not harder.
The next thing we use is Monday.com.
This is what we use for our productivity
and all of our projects.
This is where we map
things like YouTube videos
and launch schedules and
all of our admin type things
that need to happen in there.
That's through Monday.com.
And the way we communicate
as a team right now
is through a software
company called Slack.
Now this is great because it's mobile.
You can have the option of adding
as many people as your want
and it allows you to keep
communication on certain projects
separated from other projects.
Have you ever had that before
where you're talking to someone
and then they just kind of
like switch to a new thing?
And you're like wait,
we were on this topic.
How are we over on this topic now, right?
And so what we use that for is Slack.
And then Planoly.
This is where we plan
our Instagram strategy
is on Planoly as a company.
Now we also use, so these are
the four main that we use.
We use the actual scheduling
tools inside of things
like Facebook and Twitter.
The actual native scheduling
for those platforms
but you guys, this is all we're
using as a company right now
because we don't have
time for more than this.
All right, the next one is
saying no more than yes.
This is a life changer.
Now when I read through this book
and I heard say no more
than yes, that was hard
because I'm the yes girl.
I'm like "You need a leader?
"Me, pick me, pick me!
"You need someone to run this festival?
"Me, pick me, pick me!"
Right?
Like I was signing up for everything.
I was like the mom of the PTA
that wanted to do it all
and that is not going to
move me towards my goals.
And so I had to start practicing
saying no more than yes.
So here's a tool I want
you to take home with you.
When someone says "Hey
Dr. Kay, can you X Y & Z?"
I want you to say "You know what?
"That's a great idea,
let me think about it."
Because in the moment if you're like me,
which is a three on the enneagram,
you're like "Yes sign me up.
"I am ready for that,
I will lead that thing.
"I will do that thing.
"I will waste a lot of time on your thing
"because I want to please you."
And so I want you to take some time
before you say yes and
really think about it.
Is this thing going to move
me forward in my business?
Now it's okay if you feel sometimes
like this is good for me and
good for them, absolutely.
Then say yes.
But you'll start to see,
as I have in my life,
that more times than not it's
actually okay to just say no.
Because here's the thing.
Other people can do it too.
I know it's a weird thing.
I thought I'm the only
one that can do this
but other people are out there
that can do exactly what you can do.
So I want you to practice
saying no more than yes.
In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference
Grow With Video Live.
A $1500 value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe.
Leave us a review on Apple Podcast
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- And the last thing really
is in my time management
be real with yourself on your goals
versus your expectations.
This was something for me
that really had to be a mindset shift
because I have lofty goals.
I have huge audacious massive goals
where I want to make
major impact on the world.
But it's the season of life, right?
It depends on where
you are in that season.
And for this last year, for our family,
we're in a new season of life.
This January we were able
to bring another little guy into our home.
(crowd applause)
Thank you.
And with that, I'm like still
all the mom feels, you know?
(laughs)
And with that, that's a season of life
that needed to be dedicated
more to my family.
And so when you're looking
through your time management,
when you're looking through productivity,
I want you to think about
"What season of life am I in?
Am I taking care of an elderly parent?
Am I adopting?
Am I needing to actually
hustle at Starbucks
to get my thing off the ground?
Like what season of life are you in?
And be real with your
expectations through that.
Because a lot of times
the feelings of failure that we have
are actually just related
to our own misconception
of our expectations.
So number two, number two on that
was the lack of resources.
Now I have been a solo entrepreneur
until the time that Sean
and I created this, this.
Until we created Think Media.
And this for me was probably
one of the largest blockers.
But one of my mentors says
everything is figure-outable.
Everything is figure-outable.
So most of the time these
are the two blockers
that come into play
when we're not going
all-in and pressing record.
Number one is people.
Let me be honest and I want
you to be honest with me.
It is hard to hire people.
It's hard.
You don't know what you
need to hire them for.
You're like, what do I take off my plate?
How long is it gonna take to train them?
What should I pay them?
Should they be a contractor?
An employee?
Does my state make me do
that or do I have to do this?
Like all of these new
things that we never learned
are now things on our plate
that are gonna help us move forward.
So people become the lack of resource
and then knowledge and skill.
Guys I knew that I was
supposed to be on video
and I waited three years.
I knew it.
I knew that the way I needed
to get my message out to
the world was on video
and I didn't do it.
I was running a digital agency.
I was helping a government agency.
I was helping other people do their thing
and I was like "You go
girl, you got that!"
Right?
But then I looked right back at myself
and I was like "I don't know what to do.
"I don't know anything about cameras.
"I don't know anything about gear."
And I waited three years
before I picked up my phone
and recorded a video.
And you know what was
really crazy about that too?
Was when you go back to the people part
and the knowledge and the skills part
all it took was one tweet.
All it took was one tweet.
I stepped out, I had courage.
I reached out to someone
that was already doing what I want to do
and I said "Let's partner on this.
"I have these skills.
"I know I know how to do this thing
"and I know you know how to do that thing
"so why don't we do this
thing together, right?"
You are in this room right now
with other smart,
purpose-driven entrepreneurs.
There is no better place right now
for you to partner with
someone than in this room.
'Cause we're on mission y'all.
Are we on mission?
(crowd cheers)
We're on mission.
You are purpose-driven!
I know that you have a skill
that you can share with someone.
So I want to make sure that you know
that people and knowledge and skills,
that's a limiting belief in our brain.
There are people that
want to connect with you.
None of this happened by just me and Sean.
This was people.
This is people.
This is other people's
skill and knowledge.
The next one.
The lack of budget.
Anyone in here ballin' on a budget?
Yeah.
(laughs)
Well like Sean said
before, guess what guys?
Your excuse is gone.
All of these are free.
And guess what?
You want to start a business?
You're like "Heather I get it.
"Social media is free, I got that."
Well guess what?
All of these things where
you can start a business.
You can start emailing
people on your list.
You can sign up for Amazon Associates
and become a person that
sells other people's products?
You can package your knowledge
on Thinkific and Teachable
and start doing the things
that are gonna change people's life.
And guess what?
See that?
Free, all free.
And guess what?
It doesn't take fancy gear.
It doesn't take a lot of things.
Guess what it takes?
That right there.
Your smartphone.
All it takes is your smartphone.
And if you need help with that
we're here for you for free.
Crazy.
We have a new series that
just came out on Think Media
where we walk you step by
step, step by step y'all,
how to go into video with
just your smartphone.
And then we also have created
free resources for you.
If you're like "Heather I'm
a step above a smartphone.
"I'm ready.
"I'm ready to go all in
with whatever Diana's using
"on her channel that looks awesome
"and what Dr. Kay is over here doing."
Like you're ready to go in.
We've prepared free
resources for you as well.
All right guys.
Now it's time to get into
those internal enemies.
Those internal enemies.
Now we've gone through the first three
and those are all external.
Those are things that
we're like "Yeah I see that
"and I can do that and
I can hire that person
"and I can do those things, Heather.
"I can do the things."
But these are really the
things that held me back.
These are the things that
I allowed to run my life
for three years.
And the first one is this.
Perfectionism.
Right, I get you, I know, me too!
This is from Beth Moore.
She said "Insecurity's best
cover is perfectionism."
That's where it becomes an art form.
That's where perfectionism
becomes an art form.
Guys, here's where perfectionists live.
This all or nothing syndrome.
Well Heather I just can't post that video!
You know, my hair was all messed up
and like I didn't even sound right
and like my kids were
yelling in the background!
So I can't post it!
Why?
Are you only gonna make one video?
Come on, right?
Oh you know, I created that course.
It's sitting on my laptop but you know,
it's like I just don't
really have an editor
and it's just, I mean
who's gonna buy it anyways?
Are you only going to create one course?
I mean didn't we hear Sean say you need
to be making bad videos?
Like let's just get that out right now.
You need to be making bad things first
because making those bad things first,
starting messy, that is
what's gonna move you forward.
That is going to be that where
someone pops on Instagram
and is like "Who is this girl?"
They're gonna be like
"Yeah did you not see
"the like 500 things I messed up on?"
No, they don't see that.
Because you started messy first.
So let's go ahead and
let perfectionism out
and let's start messy.
Next is this one.
This one gets me every time.
Scarcity.
Have you ever said this to yourself?
Someone's already doing it.
Someone's already out there.
Someone's already talking
about digital marketing.
Someone's already out there.
They're already a doctor!
I can't be online, there's
already doctors online.
Oh man, there's already a painter.
There's a painter and
she's online already.
Oh man there's a person
that's already talking about
speaking on stage.
I can't, I just can't do it.
There's just not enough
people in the world!
What am I gonna do?
Not enough people that
are gonna buy my stuff
or grow my business or anything like that.
Well I mean let's look at these.
This is digital around the world in 2019.
The total population, we're
at seven billion people?
That's crazy.
But look at that.
Five billion people
have cell phones, what?
Internet users, four billion people?
I mean I'm okay if I get 10% of that.
I don't know about you guys
but I will be fine if it's
just 10% of four billion.
Come on.
Scarcity, really?
Sean had some numbers earlier
that were active users.
These are actually just active accounts.
Like LinkedIn, your boss
said "Hey you need to create
"a LinkedIn account."
And you're like "Sure, okay,
whatever, LinkedIn account."
Right?
These are active accounts
on these platforms?
You're telling me there's not
enough people in the world?
Guys, scarcity is a mindset.
There is no lack.
There is only abundance.
And you know what makes it even better?
(crowd applause)
Is that you are here at
Grow With Video Live.
You can partner with someone.
Sean and me partnering,
that didn't make us go down.
That made us go up.
There is no scarcity.
You know we are friends
with every major competitor
in our market.
We are friends with them.
(crowd applause)
You know why?
Because all of that rises.
Someone else bringing
that to the playing field
helps us in the playing field.
If there's no one else
doing what you're doing,
that's the scary part.
But I'll bet, raise your hand,
is someone else doing what you're doing?
Raise your hand.
Someone else is doing what you're doing.
Exactly.
There is more than enough to go around.
Here's a question for you.
How many of you bought a pair of shoes?
How many of you have ever
bought a pair of shoes?
Okay one pair of shoes, that's good.
Half of you, no shoes?
That's fine.
It's okay.
How many of you have
bought two pairs of shoes?
Oh wow look at that.
How many of you have
bought five pairs of shoes?
Ten pairs of shoes?
I'm sure every person that
started a shoe company
was like "There's
already people doing it."
No.
Here's the thing guys.
There is more people in
the marketplace right now
that want what you have.
They are waiting for you, waiting for you,
to put your message out in the world.
They need it from your voice.
They need to connect with you personally.
They need to hear your story
and that's not scarcity.
That's abundance.
Here we go guys, man
let me know if this one
has gotten you before.
A lack of confidence.
Lack of confidence.
Here's where I fall into it.
Guys I am standing on a
stage in front of 250 people.
What is life right now?
This is crazy!
But this is where I fall.
The imposter syndrome,
the imposter syndrome.
Who am I?
Who am I to be the person
to be telling people how to homeschool?
I just started.
Who am I to be the person
to help someone through a divorce?
I'm not but other people do.
Who am I to be the person
that's gonna help someone
learn how to parent their kids?
Who am I to be the doctor that's online
helping someone with their problems?
Who am I to be the artist telling someone
how they should be create?
There's people that are better than me.
But you know what?
It doesn't matter.
You have permission to step out.
I want you to turn to
your neighbor right now.
I want you to look them in the eye
and say "You have permission to do this."
(crowd chatting)
Now look at the other person
and say "No, you have permission.
"You should be doing this."
(crowd cheering)
There we go.
Guys, imposter syndrome is just a mindset.
I still fight this every single day.
There are women who are doing
massive things in the world
and I think "Who am I?"
I'm just a college dropout
that lives in Las Vegas
and homeschools my kids.
But you know what?
God has woven a purpose into my heart
and I am going to stand
on every stage that I can
and empower as many people as I can
because no one is gonna tell
me that I'm an imposter.
Because if I believe
it, they'll believe it.
All right here we go.
Comparison, anyone?
Yes, oh man this one hurts.
Yes.
You know when I think about this,
comparison is the thief of joy.
The thief of joy.
I get up every single day
and I want to live a joyful life.
It doesn't need to be balanced.
It doesn't need to be perfect.
But the one thing I want to be known for
is I brought joy to the world.
And you know what happens
when we start scrolling through Instagram?
Comparison creeps in.
You know what happens when we
go to that business conference
that we're like the new
person on the scene?
Comparison starts to creep in.
And so I just want to encourage you
that you have something
great inside of you.
And your journey is gonna look different
than someone else's.
My path to get to where I want to go
is not going to be the road
that someone else went down.
I want to be a trailblazer
for the next generation
and I want to do it my way.
But this right here?
This is the what the enemy is giving me.
You're not good enough.
Who are you?
Why are you doing this?
They're so much better than you.
They're already on a yacht in Cancun.
(crowd laughs)
Not that that's where I want to go
but I want to go, I mean if
it's there I want to do it!
But that's the kind of stuff right?
Oh their family is perfect.
Oh wow, they're eating organic food.
Oh wow, she was able
to do all these things.
Comparison is the thief of your joy
and you are the one that controls that.
You are the one that picks up your phone
and scrolls through Instagram.
You are the one
that actually follows
those people on Instagram.
Here's a power tip for you.
Unfollow.
(crowd laughs and cheers)
Power tip.
Unfollow those people.
Doesn't matter if your sister,
doesn't matter if it's the guy
that's doing the other thing,
does not matter who it is, guys.
We have been tricked to think
that we need to follow
everyone in the world.
You don't.
If they are stealing your joy,
if you are not going to these platforms
and feeling fulfilled afterwards
then you need to unfollow.
I did this.
I did this practice
actually before we started
Grow With Video Live
I was feeling down.
Guys I was feeling like "Who am I?"
One of the idols that I
look up to is Rachel Hollis
and she just did a
conference with 7,000 women?
I was like well, I only
got 250 people coming.
250?
Come on!
This is amazing!
This is awesome!
(crowd cheering)
And though I love her so much
for the message she's
bringing to the world
guess what I did?
Unfollowed, unfollowed.
And guess what I wasn't doing
leading up to this event
for the last week?
Comparing myself to her.
I was letting people like
Mel speak life into me.
I was letting people like Sean
tell me that I was made for this.
I was letting people in
my life actually feed me
so that I could be here on this stage.
Y'all this is not normal for me.
This is not normal for me.
But I know that this
is where I need to be.
So here's what I want you to know.
You're not alone.
You're not alone in this.
Thanks for checking out this episode.
We hope you got a ton of value
and if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review this show
on Apple Podcasts.
- As we grow this movement
of purpose driven content creators,
we encourage you to share it with a friend
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(upbeat hip hop music)